hey everybody thanks for coming to the
talk today a lot of good talks
especially in this time slot so
appreciate you uh car out time and
coming to this one now I assume if
you're showing up to this talk that you
use pandas and interact with SLE
databases a lot and if you do that you
probably noticed that uh be kind of slow
and has some rough edges so talk about
that today and I'm going to
introduce uh these new addc drivers that
work with ap Pacho and make that much
better much faster much more so let's
just talk today though about the current
state of pandas interactivity the SQL
databases if you're new to pandas you
look at the documentation the first
thing you see is to SQL and from SQL uh
and these typically work in coordination
with a driver obbc usually or jdbc SQL
alemy is somewhere in there um you can
not use either of them if you use SQL
White 3 not a lot of people do that um
but it's there and like I said this is
kind of great when you first start out
you'll find quickly that there are
limitations with time complexity and
data type management uh today so what a
lot of people do if two SQL and from SQL
aren't enough today is end up moving
files around historically you see people
drop CSV files somewhere and the
database would pick them up we're I
think it's a society moving away from
CSV into more parket which is good but
still not every database can support a
copy of Park so you start getting into
database specific features but if you
have copy as a database uh you've
probably seen in the past that copying
files much faster than using to SQL from
SQL um and in some cas cases you may
rely on Specialized libraries so I've
done a decent amount of redshift work um
in in my day job and uh specifically
with red shift they have this Library
called AWS SDK for pandas used to be
called AWS Wrangler and they would
Implement their own kind of custom way
of taking D Panda dataframe data and
pushing it high performance into a right
shift
database okay so this is all great but
it'll be even better if tosql and from
SQL just work better and were faster we
didn't have to worry about files we
didn't have to worry about specialized
libraries and again even though we're
not quite there today uh we have uh
development going on in the ADC space
that I think will make that uh
possibility sooner than
later um so I wanted to talk about why
pandas has all these limitations today
and when I was coming up with this talk
I was kind of on the edge about how I
wanted to get into the terminology
because at the end of the day you as an
end user just want to go in and say push
it to the database or pull it back from
the database and I got by for years
without worrying about what the DV API
was and what SQL opy actually did and
all this stuff um so I don't want to go
too deep into what those libraries do
but I still want to make sure that we
have an understanding of like the
building blocks that are in the
ecosystem today and how they kind of uh
work from the ground up
so the very first thing everyone's used
the term driver before maybe without
thinking about what it what it is but a
driver is simply a library for
interacting with the database you've
historically heard about obbc and
jdbc these are both their own apis for
interacting with databases right so they
don't they aren't exactly the same uh
but you know the odvc specification may
say something like okay we need a
function that connects to the database
and we need a function that gets rows
and a function that iterates of rows and
as you iterate over rows here's what the
result should look like right so they
set up that API and the driver will
Implement that API specific to a
database whether it's SQL server or
postgress or SQL light you kind of just
use that obbc API and
work uh it's worth mentioning that obbc
and jdbc came around kind of in the '90s
and if you've been following the trends
in data analytics for the past 20 years
I mean we've started to get colum or
databases be uh more common in analytics
they weren't even around in the '90s
when odbc and jdbc were created so jdbc
works with rows doesn't even work with
columns at all obbc kind of does um but
most drivers that you use probably today
with pandas don't support that so um
there's definitely time spent and time
wasted going between rows and columns
and rows and columns between all these
tools and formats and things like
that uh which ADCC Sol so we'll talk
more about adbc later uh but that's kind
of a a pretext for that in Python today
on top of these obbc and jdbc drivers
you have the dbapi 2.0
so like I said OBC is an API DB API is
an API on top of the API um so it's
really from the python space saying like
hey I need in Python I just want to say
execute and the driver needs to know
what execute means or I want to work
with the cursor and the driver needs to
implement like what a cursor is um that
was created in 1999 again think about
the timing we're we're not thinking of
Coler databases back in
1999 if you care about all the details
look up pep
249 um and have f with that finally we
have SQL alchemy that sits on top of the
dbapi and uh basically wraps it right so
every database can have differences in
terms of syntax requirements how it
handles
transactions um seq alchy tries to
abstract this and says like hey if
you're working with python data
structures like a list don't worry that
like this database requires double
quotes for escaping and this one uses
back ticks and you know this one is
transactional or ever s Alchemy and say
okay here's a list just take this python
list and I'll take care of telling the
driver specifically what it needs to
know um and in pandas we use SQL Alchemy
they have a lowlevel API that we
utilize uh which I think is an end user
if you started writing direct SQL opy
you wouldn't necessarily use um but it
it helps Panda like not have to worry
about transaction management as much uh
there is a higher level r omm which if
you use SQL Alchemy uh directly you'd
probably use that today in own Library
code um but it's worth mentioning I'm
going to talk during this presentation
about how we don't use SQL alemy uh for
high performance that doesn't mean SQL
alemy is bad just realize that like it's
a pretty generic tool right it's not
made for high performance colum or data
extracts or data movement it's really
for generic python data structure so it
serves that purpose well but as far as
you know you as an analyst or data
engineer whatever your role is uh as far
as you may be concerned uh it's pretty
slow to do that you know which you're
used to uh in working with pandis it's
pretty jarring how slow it
is um I took this visual just to kind of
reiterate what I talked about on the
previous slide this is from the adbc
introductory um blog post as well which
I've shared the link there uh but just
to kind of yeah drive home will be
talked about visually you see in the
middle here we have jdbc and odbc API
and drivers this doesn't picture the DB
API or seq Alchemy uh but they kind of
happen on the left hand side right so
you have in that top left corner if we
were to make this specific to python all
that interaction would happen up there
uh and you see in the bottom left hand
corner you're working with roads okay so
pandas P Arrow a lot of the are not
necessarily row oriented they think in
terms of columns you get much faster
operations when you just add up a column
than when you add rows uh so that again
just visually speaks to some of the
tooling and architecture architecture
mismatches we have with those
drivers if we were to make kind of a
process diagram over how your data gets
from a panda data frame into uh database
today this would be a pretty high level
of view right and I've split it into a
python layer at the top a compiled layer
down at the botel um now if you've used
pandas for a few years you may realize
that pandas is not fast because it's
written in Python right it's fast
because python is like a rer on top of a
lot of things but usually your
implementation of high performance
algorithms is done in a compiled
language so whether it's C directly
maybe C++ we scon to do that all the
heavy lifting is done down and compiled
code and that's what makes it really
fast you're not interacting with the
python so anything in this Top Lane is
slow anything in the bottom Lane is fast
and you can see that we don't have a lot
of fast stuff in this diagr okay we have
our data Frame data underlying our our
pandas data frame down that compil space
But we're immediately the moment we use
SQL opy today jumping up and at python
run time at the top We're looping over
rows creating these strings and
statements and having the driver take
care of that for us okay so we're going
to see the comparison diagram later with
ADC much more of this gets in the
compile player and that's how we achieve
a lot better performance new
drivers okay um yeah just driving home
the limitations today I've mentioned
these already but just to explicitly
list them out data types missing uh
value support and performance are all
limitations of the current architecture
with Pandit going to SQL and I'm going
to show these in more detail on the
following slides missing values okay
we're going to connect to a database I'm
going to use postgress for this
presentation uh it's open source uh has
a rich type system inspired a lot of
other databases so this is heavily
slanted towards postris although what
I'm going to say here in theory apply to
any database um that you want so if we
connect to postgress Let's assume we
created a table in postgress you see the
comments really simple table uh it's a
integer uh column and that's it okay
this is great I'm going to read SQL and
check out my data types and you see
immediately I get a 64-bit integer back
well what's interesting is an integer in
postgress and similar databases is not
64-bit integers maybe you care maybe you
don't care about this right now um but
from the Geo I don't have the same type
as my database I've create a new type on
top of that and you know your type
mapping which we'll see in a few slides
can can be problematic from that but
even alone with missing
values uh let's say somehow in my
database in value correct in I didn't
have a not constraint or my database
didn't en force not constraints I run
that same read SQL statement and now I'm
getting float data back okay so this has
been a problem with pandas for as long
as I've been involved with the project
goes back quite a few years uh something
we've worked on in the past few years to
to make our type system more reliable
but going from an integer to a float has
a lot of uh implications in terms of
like accuracy see you know in terms of
um how big of a number you can represent
right so there's a lot of downsides to
go into float that as you work with it
more I mean maybe when you first start
out you don't care about this but the
more you work with it you know if you
want an integer column to stay in
integer it's really tough today with the
current
drivers um and what this does is it
forces you to manage types from your
code right so if I really wanted my
integers to stay integers I have all
these different methods have to go
through in today's world to make that
happen um the first way is to be really
explicit in pandas that hey I want
integer T types uh that's going to fail
throw an error if we get no values in on
the previous slides so it could be a
viable option if you want to be super
strict but uh you know I don't know if I
would want my jobs to fail just because
a no value came in that's kind of
heavy-handed it's up to you um you could
also Al so just say hey exclude anything
that's not null um maybe this is viable
with one column but if you have a ton of
columns it's a huge pain and you know
maybe you do still want to know if
there's no data coming in you've changed
your query by doing this to appease the
type
system in really old versions of pandas
before we had n nullable
integers if you wanted to get back to an
integer you had to go through this thing
where you write the data kept as a float
then later on you'd you know get rid of
the missing values and do an as type
okay so you're doing all these
gymnastics to get back to like the
integer data type that you want
originally uh which is also kind of a
pain okay so three options there I can't
say which one's the best don't worry we
have more
options um in more recent versions of
pandas you could use nullable integers
so if you change your lowercase ins to
Capital I ins you get a knowled a
nullable integer back so you see in this
case I actually do finally get a 32-bit
integer like I had in my database to
begin with um and since pandas 2.0 we've
started to add this D type back end to
some IO methods right so you could use
that here to say I I'll allow nullable
numpy types or P data types and
depending on the back end I've chosen
I'm either getting back capital i 64 or
lower case I in
64 okay so that's I think six different
methods I just went through which one is
the best I don't know probably since 2.0
I'd go with one of these but it's really
dependent on your use case and that
makes things much more complicated than
they need to
be uh relatedly if you wanted to read in
a table and write it back to the
database kind of the way it was it's
really difficult to do that because all
the gymnastics you just saw on the
previous slide right so let's say uh
I'll go back to my previous example and
the proceeding slides I'm just going to
read in this one column um and it's
going to give me back a 64-bit integer
even though I created an integer to
begin with in my
database if I write that back to a new
table you see my types aren't really
matching right so it's really hard to
get your data types correct if you
create new tables you're kind of just
you'll you'll probably by default get a
ton of 64bit big ints or whatever data
type your database has um so yeah that's
pretty
annoying and performance okay this is a
a fun topic again I'm just going to
create a SLE data frame here the data is
not important I'm just taking
uh random integers a million rows by 10
columns pretty simple um there's a
million different benchmarks you can do
here but if I were to time how long this
took to write to my postgress database
today if I just use two SQL out of the
box what that does is it creates one
insert statement per row of data so if I
had a smaller data frame 3x3 values 1
through n I'd basically be sending three
different insert statements to the
database today and um it's kind of slow
right so it probably took me less than a
second to create that data frame I just
showed on the previous slide but it
takes me over 22 seconds to write into a
post database if you've used other iio
methods in pandas that's super slow CSV
is probably less than a second even
Excel which is a slow format I think
would run laps around this um so not a
great start but if you've read the two
SQL documentation you see we have all
these options that you can use to tweak
how you want these uh SQL statements to
go to the database and hopefully make it
faster the first one is Method equals
mul sounds great instead of doing one
insert statement per row I can just put
everything into one big insert statement
right so if there's any overhead to
doing an insert statement in my database
in theory I've gotten rid of this um and
what's funny is you know I consult for a
living and I pretty sure I've told a lot
of people that this is faster um and a
good thing to use instead of the the
standard default well when I was going
through this presentation I found out
that I was horribly wrong probably been
giving bad advice for you know five
years in that
front you can see here we went from 22
seconds to 2 minutes just by changing
that one keyword that we thought was
going to help us with
performance and that is not good super
slow but don't worry there's still more
options we could tweak so we have method
equals multi and we could add a chunk
size into that okay so now I can maybe
get the best of two different worlds and
say okay well an insert statement per
row is is probably too many inserts but
I can't do it all at once because of a
huge statement I'm sending to the
database so why don't I chunk it up and
say okay I some chunk size just send
that many insert statements into the
database uh with our simple example
again if I had values 1 through n in a
3X3 data frame and I did a chunk size of
two I end up with two insert statements
the first one takes two rows and the
last one takes whatever's left
over so I was really hopeful that this
was going to be faster than the standard
2 SQL U because it's documented as being
such it wasn't as bad as the previous SL
but it still took 24 seconds where our
Baseline to begin with was 22
seconds um and what's interesting here
you know we could play The Benchmark
game for days this is a a very simple
Benchmark with just integers I think if
you you had different data types maybe
strings this probably would be
faster um I honestly couldn't tell you
like which one to use
one so we've gone through three options
there's a
fourth uh if you've ever gone in detail
into the Panda's two SQL documentation
you can write your own method for
inserting things
okay um this was faster you got us down
at a two seconds which is isn't bad from
22 seconds to begin with definitely shap
a lot of time out of that um the code
looks something like this I don't want
to spend a ton of time in it you can
look at it from the
documentation but basically this this
user this was I thought super smart but
what they're doing is creating a custom
method for postgress that says I know
the syntax that postgress needs to
create a copy statement so I'm just
going to build a huge string that says
copy a and c and put all my values into
it so it's kind of like if you were to
do copy from directly in psql I don't
know anyone that's ever done this but
for a demonstration it's kind of just
pushing it all into the copy itself and
letting the database take care of that
um so yes that is faster copy is a
faster method but it it still has
downsides right I mean one you as an end
user need to maintain that function have
it somewhere in your code um and yeah it
it basically assumes that like whatever
I make as a python string will appease
the database in the format it requires
which is not always
true so knowing that we have all these
like caveats with performance there's so
many ways to do it none are really
clearly better than the other same
comment with data types um we have adbc
coming to the rescue okay so adbc stands
for Arrow database connectivity
if you remember the obbc and gdbc side
uh we looked at previously we had rows
in that bottom left hand corner now
we're working with arrow data so these
drivers know how to natively interact
with the database work with aache arrow
data which is a column format and not
have to take columns and transpose them
into rows or vice
versa um and yeah these are just heavily
optimized to work with Coler data sets
okay
and it has its own API as well just like
obbc and jdbc or apis adbc has its own
API
um so worth mention that everything I'm
going to show you is not something you
can use today in pandas so this is out
of the development Labs um I put the pr
that you can track this in if you're
interested in seeing the
development um pandas 2.2 should be out
for the next few months I think for the
end of the year adbc 0.8 should be out
in the next few weeks so once those two
are there you'll get all the high
performance stuff on the about to show
you um in the meantime you could still
use ADC but it's not going to be fast
like I'm showing you right so just make
sure that if you want to get the the
numbers that you see here that you have
minimum versions when you use these
libraries and this is what the process
diagram looks like with
adbc so we've gotten we've taken all
that work that we did earlier with obbc
and jdbc that happened during the python
run time and we've move that down into
compiled extensions so by avoiding that
interaction with python we were getting
significant performance speedups right
there's no SQL Alchemy required here
you're not you're not using the python
DB API uh directly you're really using
ADC and its drivers to high performance
uh transfer of
error and uh just going in the same
order we went through issues let's talk
about missing value handling okay so
this is what it looks like to
use um read SQL with the ADC driver I'm
really still just calling read SQL and
in this case I'm specifying a dtype
backend equals Pi Arrow which means like
just give me the pi Arrow or the arrow
types back don't do any kind of
translation of the types
um and in this case I actually finally
did a 32bit integer as stable without
having to specify anything okay so this
is like the only method that we've seen
so far that actually can produce or
reproduce whatever types are in the
database in the data that you're working
with locally which is
fantastic if I insert an old value back
into that sample table nothing changes
it's still a 32-bit
integer uh Arrow data types are at least
integer data types are nullable so I'm
not changing my data types because the
data change in datase much simpler that
way uh relatedly I can actually round
trip things right because these types
match what I get in the database if I
read a 32-bit integer from the database
and I write it back all in
pandas um I get the same exact table
that I started with okay so previously
when we wrote it back we got a big in
now we're working with an integer so
aside from constraints and other
metadata that might be attached to the
table if you're talking about strictly
the types and the data itself you can
replicate that round tripping with thec
drivers and
performance this is this same
code and uh I'm just calling two SQL
here now I'm down to 658 Mill seconds
out of the box I'm not changing any
other settings I'm not creating these
custom copy commands I am simply saying
use the adbc driver write this to SQL
and I've gotten faster performance than
any of the other Hoops that I had to
jump through the first time around I
mean by default I think the default with
obbc was 22 seconds so this is 35 times
faster just by using a different dver
which is pretty nice
and uh just to put that visually for you
um there's the default somewhere about
20 seconds the multi method that I've
mistakenly advised people to use in the
past was 120 seconds um copy was okay if
you if you could do that manually but
ADC again no extra configuration no
extra code you're picking the driver we
getting better data types and the
performance throughput is just insane
because we're not trans closing between
rows and columns we're avoiding the
python runtime all in all it's just a
better design to start to finish um and
you just see that played out in the
numbers kind of a bonus is a better type
system um so this is a not necessarily
complete listing of all the different
types used across uh different databases
open source ones as well as
uh I I called it numpy pandas right so
pandas has used numpy historically as a
as a backing so these are really numpy
types but what you would see through
pandas and then we have Arrow post white
uh and I've tried to line up where they
all kind of fit and match one
another and uh you can see that Arrow
has really nice rich data types beyond
what pandas offers out of the box uh
that match what a database like
postgress and any other database in
theory would allow
for so kind of that
first first thing that doesn't have a
value for pandas is tapes um I've run
into this issue a lot of times
especially with people new to pandits um
that they don't realize there was no
date type in pandits there's only a time
stamp or a date time really um so I've
seen a lot of people you know collect
all these datetime date objects into a
NP array which is really a object type
in numpy they WR to a database they
can't understand why they're not getting
the right data why it's so slow why the
data operations don't work well Arrow
has an actual date data type so if you
wanted a real date in your target
database you can use the arot type
system to accomplish that uh binary data
I'm not sure if there's that many people
that would use that but it's an
opportunity there you see even at the
bottom there's decimal arrays composite
now I put an asteris next to those and
arrow because I know for a fact that
they haven't been implemented in the
driver yet but there could be a future
where you know if you have list data or
an array data that you want to keep in a
column in your database that you could
write them through the ADC driver as
long as your Source data has that same
data type as well I don't think that
would be possible at all with ODC at
least without some significant rewrites
to the pandas archit
um so yeah generally you just get a much
richer type system the types match
better um and it just gives your uh it
lets the driver do a lot more heavy
lifting that you as a developer really
don't or shouldn't care about you have a
data type here you want a data type
there just send it and let the driver
take care of all the work for
you okay let's talk about ADC itself for
a little bit again I mention this is the
aerody database connectivity placing
obbc and jdbc it's pretty new so that uh
blog post that was in one of the earlier
slides I think was um created in January
of this year right so it hasn't been
around that long so there's still lots
that can be done to make these uh better
number one is like more drivers can be
produced so this is uh development
documentation as to uh what is available
today so we talked about in this
presentation the postgress driver a lot
SQL light is there as well if you use
snowflake there's a snowflake driver big
query was implemented maybe last week so
that's like brand
new um and then flight sequel which I'll
talk about that more in the next slide
um is there as
well so there's still databases missing
here right I mean see server is really
popular we don't have ADC for SQL Server
I think that would have to be
implemented there's a million different
databases out there so as long as that
gets implemented it would be able to to
leverage that but there's still work to
be done to actually create that is there
a question in the back I I'm just
confused how you could do adbc over jdbc
oh yeah that's a good question I
actually don't know all the details
myself either um so I'd have to refer
you to another developer on that but I
believe it's just um
they're basically taking the adbc API
and making it work on top of jdbc so so
you get the types but but it's not
actually doing the columns like it's we
The Columns I wouldn't expect this like
high performance out of it or anything I
think it's just like a baseline
compatibility there um and I didn't
mention them before there's actually a
turbo DBC which is another set of of
drivers and they kind of do a similar
concept sitting on top of obbc
um that's separate from adbc so try and
keep your dbc's all different get kind
of confusing but um yeah I I don't think
with that particular bridge on top of
JBC it's just compatibility it's not
high level
perform
question not yet yeah one I don't know I
don't know uh that was I think the big
query one literally went into the
development system like last week so uh
I don't know a lot about I just saw that
was there um but that thanks for
bringing that up and you see the
footnote down there anything that's um
listed as a support line just see is
really available in go Python and ruy so
this is a python conference right I
think we're mostly interested in Python
but you know if have another uh
requirement um for go or Ruby or
whatever um you could use that I think I
think R works as well I could be wrong
on that but um I'm pretty sure R can Le
se's C Baseline dagers as
well so yeah uh hopefully we see more
over time as there's more interest and
people start to see the value in it um
if you would like to get involved I mean
there's plenty of ways to get involved
um and depending on like what your role
is and what your interests are I think
even if you just are a consumer of these
drivers start using these when they
become available um if you use P
directly you can work with adbc a little
bit more low level but if you're a
handed user as I mentioned with 2.2
coming out the next few months um you
can start leveraging these and not have
to change anything in your code besides
the driver that you depict um so make
sure you know use them file bug reports
give feedback it's all pretty new right
so any commentary that you have is
welcome I think um on the project um a
pachero adbc on GitHub if you're a
library developer and um you want to
work on you know some of those things
that I mentioned maybe like postgress
you really want to implement the list
type in the driver or maybe you want to
build a SQL Server driver as well I
think all those contributions are are
very welcome and what's great is any
language that error supports could work
here as well so we saw the C driver
previously now that's Limited in terms
of like what other languages can build
on top of that but I think having the
driver in any language of your choice to
begin with is kind of the most important
thing and then the the support compati
ler um finally if you're a database
developer you may want to implement
flight SQL now I don't want to go to
what flight SQL is I honestly don't know
all the details myself um but at a high
level flight SQL and ADC are kind of
like hand in hand except ADC is more
about like a client interacting with the
database flight SQL is a database you
know saying how clients can interact
with it essentially so uh flight SQL if
you decide to use it uh in your database
that you may be developing you get
Authentication and some connection
handling out of the box and any flight
SQL driver uh which we saw on the
previous slide will work with your
database so you don't need to create a
separate driver on top of that which is
really nice um and a couple of databases
have already done this Dro and influx DB
if you use either of them um just
because they've implemented flight SQL
they have a driver you can connect to
them and start working with them
way and that is it for my presentation
so I'm happy to take any questions you
may
have so you mentioned uh basically
column uh data yeah um like this
approach of course is good but aren't we
trying to use relational database for
what they were not designed for like how
this would convert saving all your data
sets in par pile yeah did you
benchmarking or not uh well okay so the
question is kind of like how you know
with databases justly be Pro oriented
like yeah how this kind of compare
to park well it kind of depends on your
database right so so I use postris as an
example here because it's easily
available but postr probably still isn't
even the best use case for ADC because
it is still a roow oriented database so
when I'm working with my pandas data
frame and working with arrow data that
starts column I still do spend a little
bit of time and effort with post
specifically to turn that into rows and
push that to the row oriented format
that uh that post needs now if I were
working with like a colum or database
what's great is I don't need to do any
shifting of my data I start with columns
I end with columns right there's no
transposition of that in between um so
with your question about par that's kind
of why a lot of databases I think
historically have used
paret is an ingest forut especially if
they're colmer and it's it's faster to
spit out a paret file and copy that
paret file into your dat because with
that you've kind of done that work
manually of saying from start to finish
here's colum data and that that Target
database may know how to ingest par
super fast um so I haven't done any
specific benchmarks
around you know how that plays out
across all these different databases but
the theory is that it should be faster
than that because or at least the same
performance and you're getting rid of
that step to manually create
F question Here Yeah you mentioned the
the I wonder
on how that might apply
here know I don't know enough about SQL
opy to really answer that I think
um
but I think it would be hard right I
mean anytime because SE opy is really a
python Library anytime that you're
taking your data into the python runtime
you're paying a you're you know there's
a hit to that performance P right so
unless they really changed their
architecture and decided that they
wanted to work with objects lower than
level it's never really like going to
compete with the performance here at
least I
think yeah so how do we actually use ABC
with with a data frame like with the lat
stand us just the
sequel specify that uh let me let me
come back to um right here let's do this
right so assume you have uh pandas 2.2
when it
releases um the ADC Drive drivers are
distributed as their own python packages
um so you can see in this code I'm doing
from ADC driver post SQL import DB API
and then all I'm doing in in that bottom
section is saying okay with that DB API
connect my database there's my
connection information
post um use that as my connection that's
that's it right so it fits pretty well
into um what you've always done in
pandas really like you just use that
that driver specifically to connect and
um okay that may be a little different
historically like you probably SQL
Alchemy and use SQL Alchemy connect or
engine connect whatever it is um but
otherwise it's pretty minimal change to
have to De um so you'll see those ADC
drivers now on piie version
0.7 um like I like I mentioned at least
uh postgress
I know and flight SQL are there on Pi
pie I'm not sure about the other ones
that they've been packaged and put up
there but you can use them
today uh is there a reason that's not in
the connect
URL uh is there a reason what's not in
the sorry the
UMC like not recognize that or oh like
if I
I colon
ADC that um yeah maybe maybe it would I
don't know enough about the details of
that is that a seel Alchemy dialect
thing okay so there could be a future I
I've just used the ADC drivers directly
here but there might be a future where
SQL Aly can help you more easily connect
to a driver like that because I don't
quote me but I think that is a SQL opy
thing where you say like here's my
database colon here's the driver I want
to use yeah so I think it could help
there in the future but for a really
simplistic like hey we just released ADC
I just start with the point is it works
I was just curious no it's it's a good
question thanks for bringing that
[Applause]
up